bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france nouvelle journée de
mobilisation pour quelles revendications
prioritaires selon vous aujourd'hui la
priorité des gens c'est de voir une
réponse par rapport à ceux ségur et
surtout que le président a lancé
visiblement qui compte voir négociations
qui n'en semble pas encore sûr des
concertations en tout cas la priorité
aujourd'hui c'est obtenir à minima une
avancée sur l'eau socle de
revendications qui sont évidemment posée
qui sont essentiellement vous l'avez
citée dans le reportage des avancées
concernant les salaires de l'arrêt des
suppressions de lits mais surtout un
plan qui devait être un plan très fort
de formation pouvoir des embauches
immédiates pour qu'on puisse très
rapidement embauché du personnel qui
manque dans les établissements de 50 de
la santé c'est aujourd'hui est la
solution pour répondre à la crise que
traverse capitale mais la crise qui
traverse hôpital c'est une c'est une
crise qui est pas récente
la façon dont tout cas autant la
considère et la façon dont la j pour
essayer de lutter contre cette crise ait
pas d'événements récents non plus sauf
que la réalité d'avoir cette endémie qui
admire l'exergue et surtout qui a pu
porter devant la population l'état de
carence et l'état de délabrement de
l'état vision est ainsi que l'état de
délabrement des effectifs au pour les
faire fonctionner cette année les mots
qui a été la nef un élément majeur est
l'atout fondateur de ce qui est en train
de se passer aujourd'hui et la réalité
d'avoir des applaudissements tous les
soirs à 20h n'est pas suffisante dans
les journées qui arrive on sait qu'il va
y avoir une seconde vague sera pas
forcément économique mais certainement
une vague d'activité nous établissions
et on sait qu'en toute la france on
n'est pas prêts à y faire face et
contrairement à ce que dit le président
de la république n'ont que c'est pas
tout le monde que plus être pris dans le
champ c'est faux alors c'est un secteur
de la santé pas un seigneur de l'hôpital
public est ce que cela signifie que la
réponse à la crise passera aussi par une
remise à plat de l'ensemble du système
de santé en france c'est nécessaire mais
il ya un ministre qui a dit à vite et
fort
on a tendance à lui dire vite et mal il
faut il faut éviter cet écueil qui est
indiqué qu'ils mettraient leur situation
en tout cas de trouver des solutions
extrêmement rapide de bach et surtout
ses solutions sur une période aussi
courte que carl de sept mois de cette
semaine par donc il n'est pas suffisant
pour en discuter
donc nous ce que nous avons demandé bien
évidemment
dans ce c dur c'est d'avoir ces éléments
qui sont des éléments majeurs à avoir
tout de suite qu'ils adoptent mesures
d'urgence comme les revend les
augmentations de salaires l'arrêt
immédiat des fermetures des lilas
reprise immédiate de la dette des
établissements le plan de formation mais
derrière tout ça ce que nous voulons
nous c'est avoir un agenda et un
planning de négociations des discussions
qui soit concret dans l'accord de
méthode est en tout cas dans l'accord
cadre que propose le gouvernement dans
sa cellule pour qu'on puisse avoir des
perspectives qui ont des perspectives à
3 mois à 6 mois à un an pour réellement
se pencher ensemble soit devenir de
l'hôpital il pas uniquement par des
sachants mais y compris avec les
volontés de la population et des
politiques locaux qui sont très absent
en tout cas des discussions telles qu'on
peut les voir aujourd'hui comment est-ce
qu'on change aussi le regard des
personnels de santé ils se sentent
aujourd'hui des classes est déconsidéré
certains médecins de l'hôpital ne sont
plus attractifs comment est-ce qu'on
peut changer la donne selon vous on peut
dire changer la donne en modifiant
d'expression ce n'est pas le personnel
soignant c'est le personnel hospitalier
je rappelle qu'à l'hôpital tout cas y
compris le plombier qui va s'occuper de
ce que des canalisations d'eau dans les
chambres d'hôpital est aussi important
que la personne qui va faire le ménage
que la personne qui va leur faire un
point ce soir
alors moi sont des équipes hôpital c'est
une équipe sont 129 métier donc déjà
l'expression soignants nous pose
problème
donc c'est bien le personnel hospitalier
pour changer de vision il faut déjà
commencer par là il faut réfléchir de
quelle façon en tout cas ce qu'on peut
avoir un travail de fond pour
revaloriser les qualifications puisque
nous n'avons que des métiers qualifiés à
l'hôpital et surtout revoir en quelle
façon on peut m'arriver a refondé des
grilles de salaires qui doivent être
applicable notre sens pour la cgt en
tout cas au secteur privé qui soit
lucratif ou non lucratif de la même
façon puisque ce sont les mêmes métiers
donc cette revalorisation les
nécessaires et est nécessaire avec un
retard en tout cas en matière de pouvoir
d'achat mais ça fait des années qu'on le
dénonce qui depuis cette dernière année
équivaut à 20 %
donc à un moment si on n'a pas une
réévaluation à hauteur de 20% des
salaires de l'ensemble des
professionnels
les choses ne seront pas attractive ne
sont sûrs ne permettront surtout pas des
jeunes d'envisager des carrières
dans des logiques on est mal payé et on
n'a pas suffisamment d'effectifs pour
faire correctement son travail
donc c'est l'attractivité de commence
par là donc elle commence déjà par des
effectifs des rémunérations bien sûr
déshonneur et des primes sans substance
la réponse du chef de l'état face au
travail abattu par le personnel
hospitalier durant la crise
est ce que c'est le moment pour vous
aussi de capitaliser là-dessus d'obtenir
le soutien de l'opinion est ce que vous
espérez même pas voir que des des
soignants en janvier dans le cortège non
nous nous posions que la population va
suivre va venir le cortège a pris le
cynisme des dix médailles et si cette
année et minc était très très mal vécu
par tous les professionnels de notre
secteur je vous le dis parce que ça a un
côté totalement hallucinant de pouvoir
se dire à un moment on va donner des
médailles à des professionnels que toute
l'année en brie et qu'on empêche de
travailler correctement et y compris sur
le dernier mois qu'on gaz lors de
manifestations ou italiens qu'à un
moment dans les services ça a été très
très mal vécu au delà de tout ça le
cafouillage parce que là on parle de
primes qu il la prime coville est
distribuée qu'elle est partie des
personnels avec une méthode sélective
qui est fait dans les établissements qui
fait que le et l'autre ne toucheront pas
la prime pour certains ou très peu pour
d'autres donc on a à nouveau sur une
volonté en tout cas elle vouloir
satisfaire quelque chose créer un
mécontentement qui encore plus ancrée
qu'est ce que c'était avant
il sait et c'est un peu ce que nous
avons eu l'occasion de dire lors de ce
ces murs et qu'à un moment le vite et
fort et le vite et mal en il ya des
espoirs qui ont été engendrées par les
décisions et par la déclaration du
président de la république le premier
ministre les ministres de la santé
mais derrière tout ça si c'est si ces
expressions ne sont pas suivies d'effets
la déception sera d'autant plus grande
il tend but contrairement à ce que dit
le président macro il n'y a pas de
négociation dans le secure pour
l'instant de ségur et piloté par un
bernotat qui est une pilote une
commission nationale du ségur nous
n'avons pas vu de politique venir autour
de la table pour qu'on négocie vous les
gocistes et gouvernementales à moteur
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions ce matin
patrick heures bourdillon secrétaire
général national cgt santé